eh bien monsieur 19 quelle chance j'ai
eu de vous rencontrer
jamais je ne serai arrivé tout seul
jusqu'ici avec cette valise il est vrai
que je n'ai jamais porté aux balises
aussi lourde
heureusement vous êtes fait en effet ma
soeur mais je ne vois pas qui dans l'une
il pourrait porter un objet aussi lourd
est ce que vous avez entendu la même
chose que moi facteur ou monsieur du
snop ce point pour le personnage le plus
fort de l'île
ça c'est la meilleure de la journée avec
elle est bien bonne
le pauvre il a même pas de muscles
écoutez restée là vous allez voir je ne
bouge pas bonjour jury salue casimir
alors monsieur du ce nombre on a des
petits problèmes
oui je vous ai dit casey mears le fera
le plus grand plaisir
en gardant ton ironie pour toi tu me
rendre service mais bien sûr d'avoir au
fond du jardin cg suit vous il est à toi
que des tu as question idiote la réponse
tidiane le coût très élevé ce n'est pas
l'heure des plaisanteries reste pas
porter cette balle qui vient julie je me
cache cette valise et bien derrière le
kiosque près de la porte d'accord
excusez moi monsieur du snob
alors je crois mais c'est du cinoche que
vous avez oublié que casimir est un
quasi virus le vrai qu'ils sont ratera
un jeu vous observez masque du snob on
est pas un homme très musclé pas vrai 1
comment vous osez mettre en doute ma
puissante musculature
soyons sérieux se le dise normes mon
biceps ne sont que des petits toits des
petits pois qui pourrait bien vous
envoyer mes deux points sur le nez c'est
un défi parfaitement mots je suis à
votre disposition
non ce une autre image jonathan massé je
ne crains pas maintenant c'est du snob
facteurs ne vous discutez pas aller
serrez vous la main je suis désolé ma
chère amie
alea jacta est les dés sont jetés et
bien nous en avons pas c'est impossible
ouais je reçois qu'il n'est pas là kazim
effet quelque chose à nous non je trouve
ça très bien
ça va se passer par monsieur duchesneau
chaos et pourquoi moi parce quand je
suis pour le facteur ça suffit si vous
vous battez bien je vous avertis
je vous interdit de remettre les pieds
au jardin c'est impossible
il m'a lancé un défi à ça n'est pas une
raison
trouver autre chose j'ai mis des mois il
me reste des sacs de sable de mon voyage
en bateau
alors je vais les mettre dans deux
caisses celui qui soulèvera la caisse la
plus lourde sera le vainqueur
bravo casimir ça c'est une bonne idée il
me semble en effet que nous pourrons
accepter ce genre de compétition à sa
poursuite celui qui soulèvera le plus de
sacs de sable soit le mcr et casimir toi
et moi nous serons les arbitres et vous
allez voir nous allons gagner facteurs
enfin voyons que des murs il faut être
impartial un coin partial qu'est-ce que
ça aide c'est bien ou pas bien partial
impartiale ça signifie être juste ne pas
chercher à avantager l'un ou l'autre des
concurrents tu as compris d'accord je
sors à un arbitre impartial
allez vas t'occuper des sacs de sable
moi je m'occupe des deux caisses et vous
vous mettez ont tenu un attention le
perdant valérin les allées du jardin
[Musique]
et
oh
où
louis
alors deux fois trois sets et trois sacs
bon alors pour la première épreuve
les trois sacs de sable vous êtes prête
bon alors allez-y 2 3 très bien tél
après c'était plus ou moins à nos choix
et bien je vous ai préparé de verre de
grenadine au départ de julie pas bien
sûr casimir tu ajoutes un sac de sable
dans chaque est oui
serait ce serait quand même dommage que
ce soit monsieur bishnoïs qui gagne
personne ne regarde bien non attention
pour l'épreuve des quatre sacs dépêché
trois fusées ou bien aux braves en
hausse était de plus en plus durs mois
avec l'entraînement ça m'a paru bien
plus léger mais j'ai toujours soin à lee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention et prendre des cinq ça a vite
je regrette je ne peux pas facteur vous
êtes le vainqueur va gagner ça veut dire
que si non non non non non non ne
bougeait pas joli nom c'est cette caisse
m'a paru bien légère georges je vais
voir dedans j'ai fait du bien eh ben
c'est bien ce que je pensais il ne reste
plus qu'un sac dedans 20 casimir m'a
aidé je suis pas le vainqueur
je suis éliminé aurait coûté mon bon ami
le reconnaissons que nous avons été
ridicules tous les deux et puis décide
donc il n'y a ni vainqueur ni vaincu
on m'a fait plaisir mon bras si vous
voulez mais aussi et bien je préfère
vous voir comme ça tient pour fêter
votre réconciliation je vous offre du
gâteau mon coeur
le renard attendait alors s'il n'y a pas
de perdants qui va balayer les années du
jardin
[Musique]